hi
how are you hey how are you i'm loving
your leather jacket yes yes thank you
couch it's a good look it's a good look
i'm at home right now
um
and by the way i know like some of my
colleagues met you in 2017 so we're
really excited and we hope that we get
to see you back here
you know i was really excited to learn
that we are finally getting our first
southeast asian disney princess um
what's it like for you playing the role
and where and how do you draw your
inspiration from
oh my goodness um
i drew my inspiration i think from
everywhere that sounds like such a lame
answer um
i think that for me playing raz started
from finding some sort of commonality
like she's a very relatable character
you know i think that um she's someone
who saw the world in a very specific way
then this horrible thing happens and
then she sort of changes the way that
she perceives the world it becomes this
place of distrust it becomes a place of
danger um
and then
she learns how to find the good in the
world again i think that
for me
that is really relatable to just
anyone's human experience um
yeah it means it means a lot to me that
i get to i get to play her um
it's wild
yeah it's incredibly mind-blowing i
didn't think we would get to see a
sally's asian disney princess ever in my
life
um
yeah
that's crazy like let's sit with that a
second like the idea that like we all
i don't want to speak for you but i feel
like i grew up in this generation where
i wasn't really seeing
representations of myself in media or in
books or anywhere and to have a movie
like this where you're not just getting
raya but you're getting to mari and
you're getting sisu and you're getting
boone and noi and
and a wealth of characters and
recognizing that i'm you know there is a
valid experience there and
um
that is so important to me i i think
that um
yeah it's a big deal to be a part of
this movie that's sort of changing the
narrative in terms of who gets to be a
hero or who gets to be a princess
that's cool i agree i agree and you know
just speaking about experiences you know
i was born and raised in singapore i
know that you come from being you're you
have parents by vietnamese and you're
born and raised in california
how do you think ryan the last dragon
connects with youth um they're part of
the southeast asian diaspora
i
a lot
i think something that i really really
related to um
the relationship between benja and raya
was a big one for me i think that
you know i don't want to generalize
about southeast asians so i'll just talk
about my parents but that sort of
relationship of feeling like there is
honor to be upheld there is a very
specific
way in which um
ben just sort of uh
teaches raya about the world
and
there's
i don't want to say pressure i don't i
don't think it's pressure but there's
this sort of expectation
um
i really really relate to that um
there's also other parts of the movie
too that um
you know are so specific to southeast
asia the food
that was a huge part yes
right yeah the clothing the way that um
with all the five different clans like i
just love how specific everybody was
about um
the different shapes people were wearing
the different colors the patterns
everything
was so meticulously studied and i think
that you can see that for me it's sort
of that
melding of all of those different things
and when you're watching it it just
feels so authentic to that region of the
world it's really special
yeah um now i think this is more of a
personal question i know that with kobe
19 there has been like a rise of
violence towards asian americans in the
us and i just wanted to check in and ask
you how are you doing how are your
friends how are your family coping with
what's happening in the world
yeah yeah that's
awful
i mean obviously these are horrific
events and i think that
um
i think that we're living in a really
specific time where i
you know i think a lot of i think racism
always existed i think we're just now
putting a flashlight on it or a
spotlight on it
um
i think
i think you know i think that this movie
is coming out at a very specific time
for the asian community
um
because there is so much heartbreak and
there is so much uh hurt over these
obviously horrible things and to be part
of something during this moment in time
where we can sort of celebrate who we
are and be proud of that is a really big
deal to me
yeah
thank you so much for answering that
question and i hope you're doing amazing
and art going through okay
thank you so much yeah have a good day
you